[Música]
más iba movilización en Argentina en
rechazo al atentado que pretendía acabar
con la vida de la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner la que
fuera también presidenta de la nación ya
entregó declaraciones en la
investigación que se abrió por el
intento de magnicidio la gran incógnita
sigue siendo Los motivos del sospechoso
detenido
Serena Williams cayó eliminada en el
Abierto de Estados Unidos el torneo Que
ella misma había fijado como su posible
último certamen Williams se despidió
ante su afición y agradeció a su familia
Tenemos análisis sobre la carrera de
esta leyenda del tenis
la agencia espacial NASA se prepara para
el segundo intento de lanzamiento de la
emisión artemis 1 que busca poner una
cápsula en órbita de la luna como prueba
para un evento al regreso del ser humano
a ese satélite se espera la asistencia
de unas 400.000 personas en Cabo
Cañaveral
actualizamos las noticias en la pantalla
de France 24 Gracias por continuar con
nosotros Yo soy Juan pupiales y Estas
son las noticias más destacadas del
continente americano empezamos esta
emisión en Argentina en donde fue un día
de masivas movilizaciones para repudiar
el atentado que pretendía acabar con la
vida de la vicepresidenta Cristina
Fernández de kirchner la antigua
mandataria ya prestó su declaración en
medio de las investigaciones Mientras
que el acusado quien intentó disparar
este jueves sin éxito a Fernández se
negó a declarar de nuevo el expediente
figura como homicidio calificado en
grado de tentativa pero no se descarta
ninguna hipótesis el hecho enciende el
debate sobre los discursos de odio que
Podrían haber motivado el ataque y
precisamente sobre eso nos reportaba
previamente nuestro corresponsal en
Buenos Aires natalyoko soy
bueno desde el gobierno salieron
fuertemente a decir que un contexto de
discursos de odio ha sido Si se quiere
lo que permitió que surgiera una
situación como del día jueves y salieron
a pedir que se corte con los discursos
de odio que se empiece a encontrar
consensos hubo una reunión por ejemplo
hoy El presidente Alberto Fernández con
ciertos sectores de sindicatos
religiosos empresarios para de
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
también para hablar al respecto sacaron
un comunicado pero por ejemplo no
participaron de esa reunión en los
políticos de la oposición la oposición
al gobierno Y es ahí donde empieza a ver
algo de ruido hay que ver si ellos la
oposición que para algunos en el
gobierno encarnan en algunos casos estos
discursos de odio y el gobierno pueden
empezar a acercarse y dialogar para
romper con esta lógica
la Teresa estadounidense será una
Williams cayó eliminada en la tercera
ronda del abierto de Estados Unidos ante
la Australia
de César también Williams había
declarado que esta sería su despedida
del tenis profesional tras una carrera
en la que ha ganado 23 Grand slams de
manera individual
William se dio entre cese ante la
oceánica en un partido de tres horas de
duración parciales de 75 67 y 61 a favor
de Beach Serena no tuvo su mejor partido
con su servicio y terminó desgastada
físicamente ante una rival que pudo ante
los más de 20.000 aficionados que
apoyaban a Williams al término del
encuentro Serena agradeció a su familia
por su carrera y se despidió del torneo
en el que ganó su primer gran slam en
1999 Sin embargo a la pregunta de si
reconsideraría el retiro contestó que
uno nunca sabe
para analizar ese tema conectamos en
este momento con Catalina castaño
extenista profesional colombiana quien
jugó los cuatro torneos de Grand slam y
logró ser la 35 de la clasificación
mundial del ranking ella nos atienden
desde la ciudad de Pereira Catalina
Gracias por estar con nosotros Serena no
ha llegado a conquistar ese gran slam
número 24 el récord absoluto de margaret
Sin embargo creo Usted que podemos decir
que por su trascendencia Más allá del
deporte Es ella la mejor tenista de
todos los tiempos
Sí buenas noches Juan Sí la verdad que
para mí es la mejor tenista de todos los
tiempos además que fue fue de diferente
generaciones en el en el Tour y tenemos
que decir que ellas fueron las que
marcaron una etapa nueva en el Tour
femenino que fue ser más agresivos
precisamente al respecto usted se
enfrentó a hacer una Williams en 2005
Cómo era jugar contra una rival que
precisamente hizo que todas las demás
rivales tuvieran que exigirse más a
nivel físico
Bueno ese partido
yo siempre lo recuerdo que digo que el
escenario fue impresionante la altura es
una cosa increíble y además que la
estaba enfrentando a ella donde siempre
siempre el público pues va a favor de
ella obviamente por ser local Así que
fue una pues una experiencia muy bonita
y bueno enfrentar a Selena fue algo pues
de mucho impacto porque los golpes de
ella eran muy contundentes muy fuertes
Así que eso Eso Eso era lo que era
Serena desde que las Williams dejaron de
dominar el tenis no ha vuelto a ver una
gran reina una gran dominadora en el
circuito femenino vemos que cada año hay
varias ganadoras de los grandes lamps
que falta en el tenis para volver a
tener una dominadora como lo fueron las
Williams serena y Venus en su época
bueno es que mentalmente por eso es que
se dice que es de la mejor de la
historia porque Serena durante tanto
tiempo mantuvo ser número uno del mundo
esa mentalidad esa fortaleza yo creo que
no es fácil de conseguir Esperamos que
haya pues una jugadora que se mantenga
como ella lo hizo y como Venus también
durante tanto tiempo estuvieron pues
estuvo entre las mejores días del mundo
lo tenía castaño Muchísimas gracias por
este análisis y estas palabras aquí en
Francia 24
muchas gracias a ustedes vamos ahora sí
en este viernes comenzó el esperado Rock
en Río 2022 uno de los eventos musicales
más grandes del mundo tras Algunos años
de ausencia por la pandemia en su
primera jornada del protagonista fue el
metal y allí estuvo nuestra corresponsal
Valeria vuelve
el coronavirus estamos en la ciudad
olímpica de Río de Janeiro donde es 2016
aquí se celebraron los Juegos Olímpicos
ahora durante siete noches habrá
espectáculos hasta el 11 de septiembre
se prevé que 700.000 personas pasen aquí
para disfrutar de rock diversión y buena
música y quería saber creer representa
para usted el rock en Río representa una
cultura desde 1985 y este año está
haciendo el mejor espectáculo de todos
contemplando 36 años de rock aquí mejor
por qué Porque creo que es uno de los
mejores espectáculos esperados de Iron
Maiden es una de las últimas giras que
está haciendo en el mundo iba a ser aquí
[Música]
vine desde la ciudad de sino estado de
mato grosso a 2500 kilómetros de Río de
Janeiro vine para disfrutar de este
evento de rock justamente porque mi
novio Está loco por el grupo Iron Maiden
y por eso vine esta noche a honrar el
evento
[Música]
este festival también representa una
importante fuente de ingresos para esta
ciudad el sector hotelero espera tener
todo ocupado en las siete noches En qué
brazos estamos hablando de 50/2000
cuartos además se estrena este año un
escenario hecho ínteramente con acero
reciclado 104 metros de largo 175
toneladas aquí además de aeromaden habrá
grandes artistas como Guns and Roses dua
lipa y Coldplay
[Música]
lana socialista nuevamente para el
lanzamiento de su misión espacial
artemis 1 prevista para este sábado
dicha misión había sido cancelada el
lunes debido a problemas técnicos la
misión de prueba aislantes ahora para
llevar seres humanos de vuelta a la luna
y en un futuro cercano al planeta Marte
Andrés triviño tiene el informe
listos para El despegue la NASA dijo que
sin tripulación tendrá otro intento de
lanzamiento para realizar su viaje
alrededor de la luna este sábado con
pronósticos meteorológicos favorables Y
si todo sale como se espera el cohete
despegará del centro espacial Kennedy en
Cabo Cañaveral Florida a las 14 y 17
hora local la misión pretende lanzar el
cohete más potente del mundo y lleva
aproximadamente una década en desarrollo
artemis requiere de un vuelo de prueba
sin tripulación de seis semanas
alrededor de la luna
[Música]
Este es un vuelo de prueba y aunque me
siento muy bien con nuestros
procedimientos Cuando miras al equipo a
los ojos están listos no podemos
controlar el clima etcétera cualquier
día existe el riesgo de no poder
despegar Lo importante es que nuestro
equipo está listo
el lanzamiento genera emoción en el
público y tan solo algunos podrán estar
dentro del Auditorio Kennedy muchos
pretenden estar en cocoa Beach a unos
kilómetros del centro especial para ver
el acontecimiento histórico la agencia
se vio obligada a posponer el
lanzamiento de artemis programado para
el pasado 29 de agosto tras registrar
problemas técnicos A última hora
nunca he visto nunca hemos visto ningún
lanzamiento Así que eso es muy
emocionante Aunque hayamos tenido que
regresar
artemis sucesora de las misiones lunares
Apolo de los años 60 y 70 están solo el
comienzo de un programa que tendrá como
objetivo el regreso de los seres humanos
a la luna y con el tiempo el aterrizaje
de misiones tripuladas A Marte
[Música]
fin del informativo